In this video, we're going to see
another type of deep neural network, uh,
which is at the origin of
the recent advances in, uh,
training deep neural networks.
Uh,
this deep neural network is
known as the deep belief network.
So the deep belief network is I
think, particularly important to, uh,
look at,
uh,
because it's actually at the origin of
the unsupervised layer wise be training
procedure that we've seen for a
deep feet forward, no networks.
Um, and so let's look at what
it is. It's going to, uh,
have a see a lot of important concepts
in a training deep neural networks that
are probabilistic in nature.
So a deep belief network or
DBN is a generative model.
Uh, it can be an unsupervised, entirely
on supervised generative model,
which is going to mix undirected
and directed interactions
between the variables
that constitute either the input
layer or visible layer, uh,
or all the hidden layer.
So here we have an example of
a DBM with three hidden layer.
And as we see,
we have undirected connections here,
but we have directed connections
or interactions here.
So in a DBN,
the top two layers will
always form an RBM.
So in other words, uh, in this case,
the distribution over h two and h three
is going to be an RBM with undirected
interactions.
And now the other layers are going to
form a Bayesian network instead with
directed interactions,
specifically the conditional distributions
of the units in these layers,
given the layer above is
going to take this form.
Uh, so this is going to correspond to the
probabilistic model associated with the
logistic regression model.
That is the probability of say,
a hidden unit in the first hidden
layer in this case or a visible layer,
uh, visible unit. And the
visible layer is going.
So the probability of either of these
units to be equal to one is going to be
the sigmoid applied on a linear
transformation of the layer above.
So for each one that's going to be a lane
and transformation of h two and four x,
the visible layer, it's going to be
a linear transformation of a h one.
So, uh, and when we have units
that interact in this way, uh,
we call such a model as
sigma it belief networks.
So that's a model that was known before
dbs and a which was called a similar
belief network.
So to sum up in this model,
the top two layers are
going to form an RBM.
While the bottom layers are going
to form a sigma it belief network.
And think about how this model works.
For instance,
generate data to generate data from a DBN,
you will need to do gift sampling
between the top two layers, uh,
for a very long time. Uh, and
then, uh, once you've converted it,
equilibrium distribution and h two is
sample from, uh, it's uh, the actual,
uh, prior, uh, p of h two and
h three. Then from age two,
you would directly generate h one
using this, the gastric process,
these equations.
And then from h one you would generate
directly x and that would give us an
observation or a sample
of the input layer x, uh,
from a deep belief network.
Okay.
Okay. So, so sampling from this model
requires a lot of good sampling.
Add the top two layers. And then once
we've reached equivalent and distribution,
then we can a sample down, then obtain
a sample from the visible layer.
So that's generative process
associated with a deep belief networks.
So notice that a DBF is
not a feed forward network.
So sometimes in the literature you
see some people calling, uh, you know,
stacking different rbms,
uh, a deep belief networks.
I prefer to, uh, and, and,
and if you just do that to initialize
a feed forward neural network,
I would not personally called
this a deep belief network.
I would just call this unsupervised free
trading four feet forward, no network.
So a DBN is really a specific model
where the hidden units are stochastic,
there are random variables.
They're binary and uh,
they have this special structure where
the top two layers are an RBM formula in
RBM and the bottom layers, uh,
for may submit belief network.
So more specifically then the joint
distribution over the input layer and our
three hidden layers for three hidden,
they were a case is going to be a prior
over h two and h three which is going to
take this form here.
So that's,
we recognize here the
probability distribution of a
restricted Boltzmann machine
where we have our weights between h two
and h three and then the biases for the
um, uh, two layers.
And then we have this marginalization
as this a normalization constant.
So we have this prior and then uh,
we have a times p of h one given h two.
Okay.
So that's the part of the
sigma belief network that uh,
corresponds did it conditional of h one
given HD. So we notice here for instance,
that each one is independent of h three,
given h two in this model.
And then we multiply
by p of x given h one.
So x is a sample from each one using
the same weight belief network,
conditional distribution we've seen
in the previous slide. And so again,
x is only dependent on each
one. Uh, if, if we know h one,
it does not depend on
either h two or h three.
Okay.
Okay. And also in the, uh,
as sig my belief network, uh,
the full distribution of h
one given each to, uh, um,
in fact rises into individual conditional.
So in other words, given age, do,
each of the hidden units in the
first hidden layer are independent.
And similarly for a
divisible layer given h one,
if one of to look to get perhaps a more
intuitive idea of how a DBM models the
data.
You can look at this demo here online
where a deep belief networks was trained
on emptiness digits. It's a special
type of deep belief network where the,
um,
prior here actually also involves a label.
Why? So in this case, instead
of just being unsupervised, uh,
where we only model x,
we would also model a labeled y and
the labeled why would be introduced by
connecting it to the top most hidden,
they are age three.
So you can look at that at this link here.
It's pretty interesting and actually
quite impressive how good the samples can
be from this. Uh, DBM a
model train on feminist.
And,
um,
what makes this model interesting is
that much like four deep p four node
network, uh, training at
DBN is a hard problem.
And A, actually, it turns out that, uh,
a good initialization can play a really
crucial role in the quality of results
we can get. And this
is in fact how the, uh,
greedy layer wise be training procedure
was developed as a way of initializing
better the parameters of
a deep belief network.
And then after that it was noticed
that we could just use the same
initialization four feet
for neural networks.
And that was also working
really well for, uh, on, uh,
initializing a feed
forward neural networks.
So that's why we're going to talk
about deep belief networks mostly in,
in this course so that we get an
idea of where this came about. Uh,
how this came about,
this procedure of stacking restrictive
bolsa machines for a pre training,
a neural network.
So the idea for this
initialization procedure was that,
uh,
in order to train,
say a three hidden there DBN we would
actually go from a one hidden layer DPN.
So I want him later.
DBN would just be an RBM because if we
take the top two layers and make them an
RBM that there are no other layers
left to form a sigma belief networks.
So this would be just
the RBM part of the DBN.
So that's a one hidden layer VPN and then
we train that for a while and then we
would use it to initialize a two
hidden layer DBM where would take the
parameters here,
would use those to initialize
the parameters here in
the two hidden layer deep
belief network.
And then we would be left at a
training this top part of the DPN,
the RBM part of the two hidden layer BBN.
Um,
so,
uh,
and by keeping these weights fixed and
that's how we would sort of initialize
the parameters of this layer.
And then to go from a to B,
a hidden layer,
two or three hidden there,
DBN would again use these weights to
initialize that part of the three hidden
there at DBN.
These weights to initialize
that part of the,
uh,
300 layer DBN and then we would be left
with a training these weights here,
um, uh, to get a good
initialization for these weights.
And it would repeat that for a little
while for as many hidden layers as well.
So if there was three,
would just stop there and then there
would be a fine tuning procedure,
which is not backpropagation.
It's known as the up down Algorithm,
which we won't see, but you can
consult in the original publication.
So that's just the high level, uh,
description of the pre training procedure,
uh, how it applies in the context
of a deep belief network. And,
uh, before we look at the
details of this procedure,
I just want to give a
quick intuition, uh, of,
of what we're actually going to
try to achieve with this procedure.
So the idea is that if we've
trained a one a hidden,
they are [inaudible] or
in other words in Rbm,
then we have a model on p of x,
which uh,
it's just the marginalization
of the hidden layer for
the joint p of x and h one
which is defined by an RBM.
Now one thing we could do at this
point is to notice that, well, okay,
this p of x and h one that's really p
we can write it as p of x given h one
times p of h one and in an RBM,
the parameters that are involved in the
formula for this conditional are also
involved in the prior over h one they're
both present in both this conditional
and the prior over h one.
And so the idea when we were passing
from one hidden layer to 200 layers is to
say, well, let's separate these two parts.
Let's make the parameters here and the
parameters here different and actually
let's keep those parameters fixed to
the values we found by training a one
hidden layer RBM.
And then that's only adapt the parameters
dot are now and p of h one and four P
of h one we'll use an RBM,
uh, which corresponds.
So this would be this part here.
This would be a new RBM which with its
own weights and a to get p of h one and
it would need to marginalize over age two.
So that here would be p of h one and
but it would be when we're at the two
hidden layer DBN,
it would be an RBM with its own parameters
that are separate from the parameters
that RP and p of x given h one unlike
in the RBM where the parameters between
the two parts are actually tied.
And then we repeat this procedure for
p h one and h two we also noticed that
while Pfh one given h two that's p
of h one, sorry poh one Nah Dude,
that's poh one given h
two times a prior of HD.
If this as in this two hidden layer RBM,
if the DPN,
if this corresponds to an RBM, then
these parameters would be tied. Well,
once we fall into the three hidden layer
DBN we actually untied those parameters.
We're going to have different
parameters here. And, uh,
these are going to be different parameters
which are going to occur as fun to
the, um, parameters of an RBM,
which has its own third hidden there
and where we marginalize it out.
That's how I would define
pure h two in this model here.
And it's going to have its own parameters
that are different from those here.
Okay.
So that's sort of the high level idea
behind stacking rbms in the context of the
belief networks.
And then the following Dubios we'll
look at more of the details for, uh,
how we can actually perform this and
guarantee that we're doing effective
training.
We are effectively improving the model.
And so in the next video specifically,
we'll look at the general
tool for training, uh,
graphical models with a hidden variables
known as the variational bound,
which is going to be a tool very useful
for, uh, designing this and, and, uh,
properly, uh, designing this greedy
layer wise pre-training with rbms.